now this today president biden's border
czar kamala harris broke her 21-day
silence on the issue i have
talked with the president of mexico the
president of guatemala
we have well probably saying too much
but we have plans in the work to go
guatemala
as soon as possible given all of the
restrictions in terms of covet and
things of that nature
so she's going to visit mexico and
guatemala eventually
but not the u.s southern border and not
the children in cages
they'll just have to wait joining me now
to discuss tommy lahren host of no
interruption on fox nation and fox news
contributor
richard fowler guys thanks so much for
uh
joining me tommy i want to go to you
first you just came from the border
did you run into our vice president when
you were there
you know she must have been in
camouflage because i did not see her
there but i'll tell you this
i'm happy that she plans to visit mexico
and guatemala at some point to see the
root causes while people are coming over
here but i can tell her exactly why
people are coming over here
it is her administration the biden
administration that has issued that
cattle call for people to come over
and the root causes of people coming
over and the reason that their countries
are so messed up in the first place is
because these illegal immigrants are
paying
cartel and criminal organizations
thousands and thousands of dollars to be
traipsed into our country illegally
thus funding the problems in those home
countries so if you don't stop the
cattle call if you don't apply
consequences
it's never going to end these countries
that they're coming from are never going
to be repaired and our country certainly
will continue to come last
as it has for the entirety of this
administration richard what do you think
about that because
no matter where you stand on the
immigration reform debate
you have to admit that the policies of
joe biden and the rhetoric
of joe biden caused this crisis
uh no i won't admit that because i don't
think joe biden caused this crisis this
crisis has been decades in the making
number one let's take a down history
lane and understand this it wasn't it's
not
cartels is the reason why folks are
leaving this country the reason why
cartels exist
is because of america's failed war on
drugs which tommy forgot to talk about
right
when we created a war on drugs in this
country and we penalize folks for
having possession of marijuana and other
things what we created was a black
market and that black market is where
the cartels thrived
and when those cartels thrived they also
started importing people to the united
states on our southern border
i'm happy to see kamala harris go to
mexico and guatemala but let's
understand
donald trump had four years to quote
unquote fix the problems at the border
and he didn't so
let's talk about the facts don't give
them a chance and i think there's a fair
conversation to have about drug crossing
the border if they should be legalized
or anything
but the policy specifically when you
listen to other foreign leaders like in
guatemala
they blame the former president take a
look at this
i believe in the first few weeks of the
biden administration
messages were confusing
there were compassionate messages that
were understood by people in our country
especially the coyotes to tell families
we'll
so tommy you interview the people that
are crossing the border they say
joe biden told us to come when you talk
to foreign leaders
they say the same thing so who's right
and who's wrong
yeah i'm sorry richard but it's really
not up for discussion when you actually
speak to migrants and you actually speak
to border patrol who have spoken to
these migrants and asking them why
they're coming
and they say that joe biden sent me and
told me i don't have to go home
it's pretty cut and dried exactly while
they're coming but i also want to push
back against something that you said
in your previous statement about how
trump was not solving the problem no
donald trump was absolutely solving that
problem i was just down at the border
let me finish let me finish i was there
during the trump administration after he
implemented those policies that remain
in mexico after he sent the message that
you have to wait in line on the mexican
side
and get a number if you are you solve
the problem the problem goes away
the problem still exists today which
means donald trump didn't solve this
well
well i'm a hot being guys because we got
to go the problem is
the problem is it exists because he got
rid of himself he got rid of some of the
the remaining mexico agreements and
foreign leaders have said that the
people that are coming across the border
are saying that but it was a great
debate to have you both on
tommy richard thanks so much
good to see you